おっしゃす　ふぁい　はじめしゃちょーと
たくみです
はいというわけで夏ですね
お盆というわけでたくみが帰ってきてるわけなんですけども
我々の生活を取り巻く環境で
最も大切な建物なんだと思いますか？
コンビニエンスストアでございます。
我々の生活を取り込む中で
最も大切な店と言いますと
コンビニエンスストア
というわけで世の中には沢山のコンビニがあると思うんですけども
だろ？
僕もコンビニで2年間くらいに働いてたことがあるんですよ
たくみ：懐かしいね
で、話してたんですけど
あるある本当本当
セブンはセブン独特の
セブンの人に怒られそうだな
良い匂いがするよセブン特有の
セブン特有の良い匂いがして
ローソンにはローソン特有のく...
良い匂いがするんですよ
たくみ：今”く”って言ったよね
サークルKもサークルKらしい匂いとか
ファミリーマート的な匂いってあるんですよ　やっぱ
置いてある食べ物とか
ファーストフードとか
肉まんとかおでんとか微妙な匂いの違いで
コンビニによって匂いが違うんすよ
コンビニの違いがわかる男として
今回は匂いでコンビニを当てていこうと思います
イェーーイ
今回やる企画としては
2人で僕を目隠しして
コンビニに誘導してください
で、音楽あるじゃん
セブンとかのどんな音楽だっけ
*ファミリーマートの入店音*
店内放送が流れていて
あれでもう分かっちゃうから
耳にイヤホンガンガンにして聞きます
イヤホンガンガンにして
耳と目を隠した状態で
コンビニちょっと入って匂いを嗅いですぐ帰ってくる
ちゃんと買い物はしましょう
その一瞬で僕はもう
コンビニがどのコンビニか匂いで当てます
じゃあこの5つか
俺が100発100中
当ててやるぜ
ではいこう
ひとまず5店舗回りましょう
対象となってる5店舗を回ってまず匂いを覚えます
ではいこう
これか
まずファミリーマートの匂い嗅いできます
行ってきます
OK OK OK
わかったよ
やっぱりあるよね
あるあるある
ファミリーマートは魚っぽい匂いがします
え？
本当に本当に
ウソやろ？それファミリーマートに怒られるよ
新鮮な匂いがします
いやーまじであるよ
いけるいける
行ってくるぜい
あのねぇ...匂いがわからなかった
ほのかに香るのがセブンコーヒーだね
コーヒーの香りがすごい良かったです
いや難しいなこれは
手掛かりになったのは本当セブンコーヒーの匂いだけでした
これはね
結果的に言うと
無臭です
セブンはコーヒーの香りがあったんだけど
こっちは本当に何も無かった
いやー難しいな
次行きましょう
ミニストップ行ってきます
イオン系列かわからないけどスーパーの匂いがした